we need to know what perseus is planning
for that thing
park anything else in that printout bell
and woods pulled from the base
there's mention of an excavation taking
place in the ural mountains
yamantal our insider within the kgb
confirmed an act of operation
i thought hudson and weaver buried that
place years ago we did
perseus wants to salvage the old
mainframe dragonfish and steiner must
have left some
good [ __ ] behind steiner
send me in woods you're too close to
this mason
we can afford zero fuck-ups [ __ ]
you know there's no one better for the
job it's my call
i want mason and woods on this find that
mainframe before perseus does
i'll contact our kgb insider belikov
they'll offer logistical support
hell bellikov may want to fly the
chopper himself
whatever perseus wanted yamada i wanted
more
the first building is just over that
ridge thanks dimitri
what radio we found the mainframe woods
you know what the kgb does to double
agents
yep
da if they win this season it's almost
worth facing the fighting squad
hey i've only one hour of fuel
so after that you'll find yourself a new
ride come on let's get moving mason
that's our inside man don't want to
smell a cheap pocket caviar for you
dimitri's the real deal he knows where
all the bodies are buried
he buried that
what we're doing
heads up scout's on the ridgeline we do
this quiet mason
yeah you're the expert in quiet i'm a
goddamn onion
you should know that not bad
let's keep moving
[Music]
save some for me
[ __ ] this looks dicey but hey if it's
good enough the reds
you go first
i hope this holds
piece of cake
the old satcom building still standing
after all these years
barely
they got snipers don't let them spot you
stay low keep out of sight
good kill see any more
thank you
pain goes down push inside
i think we're in the clear damn look at
this place
my
extraction with a crane can we find the
crane
huh crossbow ball looks like hudson had
some fun here
that's not how he remembers it try the
stairwell
good thing i'm not afraid of hides
soviet engineering
let's go today
it's coming today
[Music]
oh
okay
let's go
[Music]
that's the doomsday bunker we're getting
close to the mainframe we'll cross on
that cable
[Music]
red's on the helipad better take them
out
why change it up now
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
make this
lost my damn gun you're going first next
time
i see a tunnel down here you'll have to
find another way inside
copy that what
great
damn
foreign
[Music]
what's up
oh
yeah i read you you gotta be close
over here
with the ruckus you made i'm surprised
the entire soviet union ain't up
our ass you've been busy that's what
they paid me for
you see any dick sites
[Music]
if i'm reading this map right swing a
few degrees to your left
more north
[Music]
you ask me they're here for more than
just the mainframe
steiner was working on all sorts of
crazy [ __ ] that nova 6 business was just
the tip of the iceberg
looks like they're packing up and
getting ready to move out
there what's that finger that crane
matches the dick site on this map
there's a big crane on the west side of
the base have your witch ready
it's gotta be excuse me my witch
sorry you're breaking up
they get a crane we got a chopper
[Music]
are you kidding
like your fourth of july huh
[Music]
now
keep moving
[Music]
uh
watch me check out the faces
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
12
that's
o'clock
nice workout
oh
watch the rooftop i'm moving
12 o'clock
[Music]
nice work
on the zipline
move it
oh
[Music]
[ __ ] hope this one
let's hope this one holds yeah
what i am over the extraction site are
you ready
we see you dmitry hold on we're out of
time we have to jump
let's go mason
we gotta get down there now
is the mainstream big because if it's
too big we can't lift
uh off it's regular sized
keep moving
[Music]
move it
we gotta get to that mainframe
[Music]
oh
move it mason
dimitri we're in position lower the
witch
dimitri take us
bring
up
ah whoa [ __ ] careful up there
[Applause]
come on
[Music]
[Music]
dammit they could have found it
come on pick up the bass
okay
we're clear dimitri take us home
hudson we finished analyzing that
mainframe that mason woods brought from
yamato
and perseus was looking for the names of
sleeper agents dragovich used in 68.
give us those names we'll get adler's
team to track him down
perseus erase them [ __ ] me there's only
one place you're gonna find that
information now
the lubyanka building what kgb
headquarters
why didn't perseus get them there
himself i don't know
maybe he's operating without
authorization i'll let edler know
but we're going to do this the right way
we're not going to do it at all
you